[Música]
m
gran celebración durante el regreso con
los suyos para armen wood o jiang
después de dos semanas y media de
cautiverio secuestrado junto con otros
cinco soldados armenios en la región de
guelar kunik armen regresa hoy aliviado
pero afectado
[Música]
el pueblo entero se desplazó para
recibirlo con música y danzas
tradicionales unas escenas de alegría
poco frecuentes para una población
todavía traumatizada por la guerra de 44
días en qara bagh entre las fuerzas
armenias y azerbaiyanas para sus
familiares el regreso de armen wood o ya
no tiene algo de inesperado su madre no
puede contener la emoción
[Aplausos]
decenas de soldados armenios siguen
detenidos en azerbaiyán son utilizados
como elementos de intercambio en el
marco de las negociaciones posguerra de
qarabagh la suerte de estos prisioneros
es de suma preocupación
si no puedo expresar lo que siento
realmente no puedo solo le ruego a dios
para que libere a todos los prisioneros
del mundo
ay dios si nos escuchas que regresen que
todos los prisioneros regresiva
[Aplausos]
a pesar de las festividades la realidad
es amarga la victoria azerbayana
encaraba llevó a la pérdida de múltiples
territorios y el ejército de bakú ahora
estaba en las afueras de armenia
quiero que nuestro fuego hace uno si nos
unimos y el sentido de que venceremos
no esta vez
están volcados venceremos a nuestro
enemigo
un optimismo que contrasta con la
realidad a unos 15 kilómetros de ahí en
lo alto de esas colinas los soldados
azerbaiyanos establecieron puestos de
avanzada que vigilan los pueblos
armenios
sus habitantes ya sufren las
consecuencias
que bolt hace parte de los ganaderos que
perdieron decenas de cabezas de ganado
ocurrió cerca de esta colina pensamos
que los animales habían ido a
refrescarse allá que habían avanzado
hacia su lado en la frontera luego
trajimos de regreso a los animales que
quedaban y cuando volvimos al establo
nos dimos cuenta de que le faltaban 10
vacas a uno y diez bajas al otro en
total 80 animales
a pesar de las negociaciones llevadas a
cabo por los soldados armenios situados
en una colina frente a los militares
azerbaiyanos los animales de estos
habitantes no fueron devueltos una
pérdida de ingresos que vuelve incierto
el futuro
se llevaron todo el ganado estamos aquí
con una esperanza o bien sea de una
compensación porque nos devuelvan
nuestros animales
entonces seguiremos viviendo pero el
caso contrario no tiene sentido
que podríamos trabajar
el rebaño de gaia me producía 200 litros
de leche diarios frente a los 40 que
produce hoy en día sus ingresos
disminuyeron un 80 por ciento esta
ganadera también tiene dificultades para
mantener vivos a los jóvenes terneros
cuyas madres pasaron al lado azerbaiyano
mire este stick
estos pequeños sólo tienen unos 10 días
sus madres ya no están entonces les doy
leche 6 litros al día para que no se
mueran nos las arreglaremos y veremos
cómo termina
[Música]
el problema del ganado no es el único
tipo de incidentes en la zona
un soldado armenio también fue asesinado
a mediados de mayo durante unos
enfrentamientos las tentativas de bakú
por redefinir las fronteras han afectado
mucho a la población armenia así que
algunos decidieron comprometerse para
defender el país
mika el franco armenio hace parte de
estos voluntarios nos lleva a un campo
de entrenamiento
estamos haciendo ejercicios de acercando
por un puesto de avanzada aquí hacemos
una nivelación y personas que han estado
de guerra personas son voluntarios
starting para atrás tech
para fumar
algunos participantes en el ejercicio
voluntarios durante el tiempo de
entrenamiento serán ubicados en las
fronteras a partir del día siguiente
recibirán entonces un sueldo del estado
y
en este campo hay muchas mujeres la
mayoría son entrenadas para ser
francotiradoras
cada vez que disparo lo hago con sangre
fría y trabajo mi patria están por
encima de todo
estos voluntarios tienen la convicción
de que sólo pueden contar consigo mismos
cuando se perpetró el genocidio armenio
de 1915 el mundo entero se quedó callado
en 2020 con esta guerra el mundo entero
se volvió a quedar callado
esta silencio obliga a los habitantes de
armenia a tomar conciencia de que la
guerra no está lejos
5 metros cuadrados de 10 puntos
a pesar del acuerdo de alto el fuego'
encaraba concertado en noviembre pasado
estos armenios han entendido que el
camino hacia la paz con azerbayán será
todavía muy largo
[Música]